et moi j'avais l'impression vraiment
d'avoir des seins personnellement
c'était vraiment un complexe mais les
personnes me disaient ah c'est drôle on
dirait que tu as des nichons l'homme à
nichons voilà
bonjour je m'appelle Robin j'ai 21 ans
je suis comédien influenceur et en même
temps je mets une entreprise au Kiki à
Nancy c'est des gaufres en forme de Kiki
minou alors quand j'étais petit je suis
né dans une famille très aimante avec un
papa et une maman qui m'aimait
énormément ensuite en 2008 j'ai eu le
divorce de mes parents c'était une
grande douleur pour moi et j'ai connu
par la suite une époque très difficile
jusqu'à à peu près 2014 où j'ai connu
les Restos du Coeur et ça je l'oublie
pas parce que ça fait quand même une
force ça nous rend plus fort par la
suite c'était une époque très compliqué
parce que du coup ma mère avait loué un
petit appartement comme elle avait pas
beaucoup d'argent elle gagnait que 700
euros par mois grâce à son boulot
c'était un poulailler en fait qui avait
été rénové donc c'était dans les
sous-sols il y avait beaucoup d'humidité
il y avait pas beaucoup de fenêtres il
n'avait qu'une dans tout l'appartement
c'était vraiment atroce et pendant
quatre ans on allait du coup se nourrir
au resto du coeur en 2019 j'ai eu mon
papa qui est décédé dans un accident de
travail pendant qu'il était au travail
sur la route le camion a explosé c'était
vraiment pour moi un moment très
difficile parce qu'à ce moment là tu dis
ta vie elle change c'est plus la vie
d'avant du jour au lendemain c'est c'est
fini en fait donc après ça bah après le
décès de mon père ça a été une époque
très difficile j'étais face à moi-même
parce que je devais rendre fier ma mère
ça m'a rajouté une pression en plus
parce que c'est tout ce qui me reste sur
cette terre et c'est vrai que si elle
part tu dis mais en fait à quoi sert
parce que bah tu as plus de parents tu
tu deviens rien en fait quand j'étais
jeune quand j'étais en colis de vacances
je m'en souviendrai toujours on était
tous en petit pull très très près du
corps et moi j'avais l'impression
vraiment d'avoir des seins
personnellement c'était vraiment un
complexe mais les personnes me disaient
ah c'est drôle on dirait que tu as des
nichons l'homme à nichons voilà force de
se prendre des réflexions comme ça tu
dis bon bah en fait il y a un problème
quoi dès que j'avais 12-13 ans j'allais
à la piscine avec les personnes de ma
classe je voyais les corps des garçons
complètement différent du mien les
garçons ils avaient une voix assez
masculine moi j'avais une voix très
aiguë les garçons avaient un ventre plat
avec des pectoraux très plats moi
j'avais un ventre plat avec des assez
élevé comme dessin et je comprenais pas
pourquoi j'avais tout ça c'est vrai que
mon père il me disait toujours time
brioche voilà j'avais pas ça quand à ton
âge j'avais l'impression d'être fautif
que ce soit de ma faute en fait ce qui
m'est arrivé par la suite après le décès
de mon papa j'ai fait un IRM et je me
suis rendu compte que j'avais une tumeur
bénigne à l'hypophyse ce qui fait que je
développe trop d'œstrogènes donc
d'hormones féminine dans mon corps ce
qui fait que j'ai une voix un peu plus
aiguë que j'avais une gynéco mastique
j'ai pas beaucoup de poils que mes
muscles sont très peu développés face à
ça je me suis retrouvé en fait à avoir
une déferlante de haine sur Twitter on
peut pas dire à quelqu'un c'est de ta
faute va faire du sport va faire 6 si la
personne en fait elle a beau le faire
elle a beau avoir un bon hygiène de vie
c'est comme quelqu'un qui prend un
traitement médical et on va lui dire
mais en fait tu es grosse non en fait
c'est mon traitement médical qui me rend
comme ça et bah c'est exactement la même
chose quand on me dit ça ça me rend pas
faible ça me rend plus fort parce que ça
me donne en fait à me dire que ça me
prouve que c'est pas de ma faute je le
montre sur réseaux sociaux toutes mes
séances de sport avec mes coachs mes
séances avec bodyt quand je fais des
séances avec d'électrostimulation quand
je fais des séances par exemple avec des
appareils pour avoir plus de muscles
pour diminuer les graisses tout ça et
bah je le monte sur les réseaux sociaux
mon train de vie mon hygiène de vie où
je prends soin de moi et je ne suis pas
là chez moi à me créer lasser et à faire
uniquement la chirurgie esthétique comme
on aurait pu le croire sur certaines
émissions qui montrent ça alors que
c'est pas du tout du tout la vérité mon
problème hormonal a fait que j'avais des
muscles assez peu développés donc quand
je vais à la salle je dois faire trois
fois plus de sport que quelqu'un de
lambda et surtout le fait que j'avais
une gynécomastie en fait il faut voir
comme si le muscle ici avec une boule de
graisse et cette boule de graisse là
c'est une boule graisseuse qui accueille
en fait une masse graisseuse qui se
développe anormalement chez l'homme et
qui se développe comme chez la femme
alors c'est comme si on était une fille
attention c'est pas trop sport parce que
tu vas perdre tes seins non la fille
gardera toujours ses seins peut-être
qu'ils vont un petit peu diminuer mais
elle les aura toujours un garçon c'est
pareil une fois que la gynécomastie et
là qu'elle est là on a beau faire du
sport le muscle va grossir mais il sera
toujours caché par cette gynécomastie il
est vrai que si on fait beaucoup de
sport cette gynécomastie peu un peu
diminuer mais elle ne disparaîtra pas et
c'est seulement grâce à la chirurgie
esthétique qu'elle peut être retirée et
d'ailleurs c'est ça touche quand même un
homme sur trois en France bien sûr il y
a quand même différents niveaux il y a
des gynécomasties assez fortes où il y a
des carrément des des seins on peut dire
qui tombe presque au niveau du nombril
il y a des personnes qui ont juste les
tétons qui partent en pointe il y a des
personnes qui ont un petit peu de Sein
moi c'était mon cas donc la chirurgie a
été en grande partie réparatrice
reconstructrice que esthétique c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai subi deux
interventions de chirurgie sceptique
dans ma vie là liposuccion qui consiste
à retirer des graisses moi j'ai enlevé
uniquement la graisse j'ai pas fait de
chirurgie où on a transformé mon nez ou
on a transformé ma mâchoire voilà donc
les seules opérations que j'ai faites
c'est uniquement enlever de la graisse
qui correspondent du coup à mon complexe
par rapport à mes hormones pendant le
confinement je m'ennuie beaucoup parce
que d'habitude j'allais toujours chez
mon père et bah là j'y allais plus et
puis d'habitude j'allais toujours la
semaine à l'école et là j'y allais plus
et je suis resté avec ma mère enfermée à
la maison et un voisin qui avait à peu
près 16 ans qui m'a conseillé d'aller
sur Tik Tok et télécharger l'application
et je me suis dit bah pourquoi pas le
faire et je me suis lancé j'y avais
posté une vidéo avec ma mère qui me
paraissait plutôt drôle et tout de suite
ça a percé en l'espace d'un mois j'ai
gagné au moins 200000 abonnés je me suis
dit c'est quand même dingue et au bout
de deux mois j'étais déjà à 500 000 et
puis en même pas un an on a atteint les
1 million d'abonnés et maintenant on a
un million cinq bientôt un million six
alors souvent c'est vrai que j'étais
haters mais par contre les haters je
vous adore parce que les haters vous
êtes là tous les jours à me suivre et
vous êtes là dans les premiers vu de mes
stories et dans les premiers like des
postes ou dans les premières critiques
surtout dans les premières critiques et
finalement les haters ceux que
j'apprécie le plus parce que c'est ceux
qui sont toujours le plus derrière moi
et les haters je les adore parce qu'à
chaque fois que je les vois dans la rue
et ben en fait finalement ils assument
pas une fois j'étais au Parc Astérix à
Paris il y a un petit jeune qui vient
vers moi il me dit Robin je peux prendre
une photo avec toi je dis bah écoute pas
de souci avec plaisir et là d'un coup il
me dit ah mais oui mais j'ai plus de
batterie sur mon téléphone je dis bah
écoute il y a pas de souci je peux
prendre avec mon téléphone et puis tu me
donnes ton Instagram et je te l'envoie
tout de suite il me dit d'accord on
prend la photo il me donne son Instagram
je vais dans messages et là je vois des
insultes espèce de con voilà et cetera
et cetera et là je dis mais pourquoi tu
m'as envoyé tout ça et là il me dit bah
parce que en fait le problème c'est que
quand on vous envoie des messages vous
répondez pas et alors quand vous vous
envoie des insultes et bah vous répondez
et là je dis mais jeune homme tu te
rends compte que là tu tu viens prendre
une photo avec moi alors que tu as
l'idée des horreurs comme ça juste avant
par message il me dit non mais c'était
pas méchant c'était juste pour que tu me
répondes je me serais excusé je dis oui
mais tu sais que en fait il suffit que
la personne qui est derrière c'est pas
un robot c'est des personnes qui sont
des humains tu vois je suis un humain tu
vois j'ai de la peau comme toi et bah si
tu dis des horreurs comme ça et bah il y
a des personnes qui lisent ces messages
et ça peut les rendre fragiles et leur
faire du mal tu vois et là il me dit oh
je suis désolé et là il a commencé à
pleurer et là je me suis rendu compte
que finalement des fois les haters c'est
pas seulement des gens qui t'aiment pas
c'est des gens qui veulent se faire
remarquer moi quand je fais issurgie
esthétique et quand j'en parle sur mes
réseaux sociaux c'est surtout pour
partager ce que je fais apporter des
réponses et aussi pouvoir prévenir par
rapport à mon problème et à mon cas
personnel si des personnes sont dans le
même cas que le mien répondre à leurs
questions et à pouvoir être là pour eux
en message privé ou alors dans la vie de
tous les jours quand on vient me voir à
ma boutique ou dans la rue voilà c'est
pour ça que je fais ces stories en
grande partie c'est pour tout simplement
parce que je suis quelqu'un de
transparent je vais pas faire un
placement de produit pour une crème
amincissante si juste avant j'ai fini
possession voilà c'est important d'être
entier avec ma communauté et je me cache
de rien il y a des personnes qui ont
fait la chirurgie qui vont jamais le
montrer et qui après vont dire que c'est
grâce à des crèmes qui les ont ces
résultats là non au bout d'un moment il
y a soit eu un lifting soit il y a eu
quelque chose ou voilà mais des fois
c'est un peu faux moi je suis dans le
réel je suis dans le je suis dans le
concret j'ai fait une chirurgie je
l'assume j'ai pas me cacher de toute
façon la
sort toujours c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
que je suis là à me défendre dans cette
interview pour montrer que finalement le
Robin en fait c'est pas un flemmard qui
en fait ne fait rien de sa vie et qui
vient faire une chirurgie esthétique tel
un influenceur superficielle de Dubaï
non c'est pas tout ça c'est un Robin qui
a des complexes depuis son plus jeune
âge c'est un Robin qui a souffert et qui
souffre peut-être aujourd'hui après ça
me regarde personnellement mais je sais
que je suis fort mentalement pour
supporter toutes ces critiques et c'est
pour ça que je suis venu le défendre
dans TPMP pour montrer en fait la
personne que je suis réellement